In this video,
we'll discuss a very
interesting relationship between
sparse coating models and
a v one neurons.
Yeah.
So v one is a region in the brain
that is part of the visual cortex.
The visual Cortex is responsible for,
uh, visual processing in the brain.
And, uh, what's special
about the one is that it's,
it is fairly well known and
well understood compared
to other regions in the
brain.
And in particular their neurons that are
there are a well known for being able
to detect a very simple
specific edges in images.
So that is very a simple contrasts
in a elimination in images.
And each neuron is really a
responsible for detecting, uh,
detecting these edges at different
positions and different angles in,
uh,
and someone's field of view.
And so a very famous experiment was
to see what, how this compared with,
uh, a, as far as coding models does.
So does as Parsco Inc model
learn features that are, uh,
similar to the types of features that v
one neurons might be extracting in the
visual field.
So they experiment that was done is
to take a image of a natural scenes,
like a big image like this
with some trees and uh, uh,
a mountain behind and so on. And then, uh,
because this is a very large image
and it'll be compassionately, uh,
expensive to actually train as part
getting model on this whole image,
we instead take certain regions in
it and extract patches from it. So,
uh, so for instance,
from a, you know, these,
we'd get patches that look kind of like
that part of a tree and then we have
some background behind it. Uh, so this,
these patches would look at this part
of the tree here and I should say I'm
giving the reference for the image,
but this is a, uh, did, did, uh, uh,
an experiment based on that.
But the actual experiments,
the first experiment on this is
a, is not from, from this paper.
This is actually an extension of sparse
coding, which is actually worth reading.
Okay.
The actual reference for this experiment
is this paper here by all cells and
fields is a very famous paper. And so
they took these natural image patches.
So we say patches because it's very
small portions of a much bigger image.
And they, uh, train a
sparse coating model,
a variant of this possibility mandala
was described in the previous videos, uh,
on these patches. And then they looked
at the features that were extracted.
So here we have a visualization
of these features.
So for each neuron,
each element in my
sparse codenamed Vector,
a I day essentially looked at at,
so at the Associated Adam,
also the dictionary column and
visualized it. And when we look at it,
I'll,
each neuron actually seems like a look,
like it's actually extracting a
Ajay formation. So for instance, uh,
this, uh, let's say this
neuron here seems sensitive.
If we have a sharp contrast change where
we go from white and then black and
then white. So that's, that's an edge. Uh,
we have another one here, which looks at,
again, an edge, but that is with this
angle as opposed to this angle, it's,
that corresponds to a slightly
different position in the patch. And,
uh,
we see there's a big variety
in the position of the
edge that's being detected,
a,
the orientation as well as
well as the scale or um,
the uh, and signal processing
term, their frequency of the, uh,
of the edge and a,
so actually each Adam will say
is tuned to particular, uh,
position orientation
and spatial frequency.
And we see something very similar,
similar in v one neurons where, uh,
we actually have neuron cell are tune
again to the detection of particular edges
but with different position orientation,
then spatial frequency
in our field of view.
So this was a very surprising
discovery by Alsace and, and feel,
which, uh, really motivated
the exploration of,
of sparsity in the neural networks.
So it really suggests that the brain
might be doing something similar.
It might be trying to learn a sparse,
a representation of our visual stimuli,
uh,
such that it maintains as
much information, but that
it is sparse in sparsity,
might just be related to the
fact that, uh, neurons, uh,
waste energy when they are firing.
So they don't want to have, uh, uh,
they want the fire all the
time. So that would be the, uh,
so this sort of energy consumption,
a constraint would be related to the
sparsity constraint and as far as coding.
And so this has motivated a
lot of researchers to look
into many more variants
of, of models with, uh, uh,
which look at different types of sparsity
and actually a lot of other variants
of the sparks scoring models,
which are not technically sparse coding,
but in core incorporate the notion of
sparsity as been shown to also extract
these types of, uh, uh, sparse
features. So edge detectors, uh,
at different positions and uh,
and uh, frequency and so on.
And so there's a huge body of literature
on different types of models on
supervised more leg track sparsity
that extract features and are based on
sparsity a notion of sparsity.
And I encourage you all to go look at
this literature and also look at a website
of, for this course, for
references for such models.